hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt einen wunsch rezept und zwar
ist es dass wunsch rezept von unserem
kamera tom tom hallo ich hab gedacht
kommt vor die kamera ok dann halt net
also heute gibt eine spaghetti pfanne
mit kartoffeln eigentlich ganz untypisch
ein sprecher der telekom
also es gibt keine spaghetti fahne
sondern eine tagliatelle pfanne denn wir
haben italien
ich weiß es sagte matthias keller was
heißt ali atalan spricht es gehe nicht
aus also hier vorne stehen die zutaten
ich habe hier ist 750 gramm tagliatelle
eine weiße zwiebel ich habe hier noch
zwei rote zwiebeln und 2 knoblauchzehen
getrocknete tomaten öl eingelegt dann
brauche ich oliven und peperoni die sind
ganz scharf ich habe ich 700 gramm
geschälte kartoffeln und petersilie so
etwa einen halben bund und da fehlen
jetzt auch der rucola aber den druck
oder hatte murat leider vergessen
mitzunehmen und er muss einfach schnell
holen
ja leider also dem rad geht und wir
bereiten das konzepte lange vor
denn das geht jetzt auch nicht zu lange
so jetzt muss ich zuerst einmal die
kartoffeln würfeln das könnte jetzt
entweder mit messern machen ich nehme
jetzt den food prozessor dafür dann habe
ich gleichmäßige kleine würfel
und mit dem stöpsel kann man immer den
letzteres noch durchdrücken
als nächstes gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen
olivenöl in die heiße pfanne und da
kommen jetzt die bratkartoffeln mit rein
da kommen jetzt die kartoffel mit rein
und da raus werden
und das mache ich jetzt in zwei
portionen damit sie schön knusprig
werden
während die kartoffeln hier noch
anbraten kann ich schon mal die
restlichen zutaten klein schneiden sie
zwiebeln schneidet inhalt bringen und
den rest schneide ich einfach schön
klein
die
hmm
die zweite person kartoffel ist jetzt
auch gleich fertig und jetzt kann ich in
der zwischenzeit schon mal den nudeln
kochen gebe ich einfach ein bisschen
salz im 2
jetzt nehme ich die kartoffeln hier raus
und kann die hier erstmal lagern kommt
nochmal etwas olivenöl in die pfanne und
da rate ich jetzt erstmal die zwiebeln
und die knoblauchzehen an
und während die zwiebeln jetzt noch
klassik angebraten werden kann ich auch
schon mal die petersilie klein hacken
der rucola es bereits auch da und den
habe ich auch schon gewaschen und dann
können wir gleich alles zusammenfügen
jetzt geht sich die nudeln ab und fang
auch etwas vom nudelwasser auf da kann
nämlich jeder der später noch ein
bisschen das ganze flüssige haben möchte
kann sich noch ein bisschen nudelwasser
nehmen und die nudeln die zwiebeln sind
jetzt auch schon soweit stadt gebe ich
jetzt die kartoffeln mit dazu
jetzt wird sich die kartoffel vater noch
mit bisschen oregano salz und pfeffer
und jetzt muss eigentlich alles nur noch
zusammengefügt werden
und das mache ich jetzt hier einfach in
einer großen schüssel
jetzt muss alles jetzt noch vermischt
werden und zum schluss gebe ich dann den
rucola und die petersilie mit rein was
regt auf jeden fall schon alles sehr
lecker
so jetzt zum schluss zum schluss noch
die petersilie und den rucola eigentlich
auch schon fertig ich glaube den rest
gebe ich beim servieren mit dazu denn
meine glasschüssel ist leider ein
bisschen zu klein
so jetzt kann ich schon servieren
und weil das jetzt toms wunsch ritter
vertrauen auch gleich probieren aber ich
feiere jetzt das ganze noch und zwar mit
etwas zitronenschale april dann müsst
ihr natürlich nicht bio zitrone nehmen
dass dringend etwas frischer mit ins
gericht und etwas parmesan käse und dann
hat man ein schönes leckeres rezept was
auch nicht so schwer ist ist es
vegetarisch und richtung aus ali k
glück sieht es jetzt keiner will ich
dieses
heute
wenn man möchte kann man natürlich auch
noch ein peeling kerne mit drauf geben
die muss man aber vorher in der pfanne
auf jeden fall etwas an rissen ohne fett
also das wäre nochmal so ein
i-tüpfelchen echt klasse sagt atomforums
rezept und will jedes rezept nach rezept
nach machen wolltest angeht auf cds -
blog.de das stets noch mal ganz genau
und falls ihr wunsch rezepte habt dann
schreibt sie einfach in die kommentare
ich glaube als nächstes machen wir ne
murat hat schon wunsch rezepte gab mehr
als genug
ich glaube ich mache als nächstes ein
rezept von euch auf jeden fall nach also
viel spaß beim nachkochen und bis zum
nächsten mal probiert mir
mobil
hmm